wie krank ist gut ihn wirklich seit
monaten wird darüber spekuliert doch wie
es dem präsidenten wirklich geht es
streng geheim so geheim dass seine
leibwächter offenbar alles unternehmen
und auch alles mitnehmen um dieses
geheimnis zu wahren
wir wollen mutig stark männlich
selbstbewusst wladimir putin inszeniert
sich gerne als inkarnation des starken
mannes ob beim angeln mit freiem
oberkörper oder beim reiten doch das
bild vom starken unbesiegbaren man es
hat kratzer bekommen
spekulationen um den gesundheitszustand
des russischen präsidenten gehen seit
monaten um die welt befeuert von immer
neuen bizarren
haben dass die russischen
sicherheitsdienste alles tun um den
gesundheitszustand des präsidenten
geheim zu halten auf auslandsreisen hat
putin angeblich eine eigene toilette
dabei aber nicht nur das die
hinterlassenschaften des präsidenten
sind offenbar top secret
leibwächter sollen nach dem
toilettengang die exkremente des
präsidenten in einem spezialkoffer
zurück nach russland fliegen damit kein
ausländischer geheimdienst an die
präsidiale stuhlprobe kommt und
rückschlüsse auf putins
gesundheitszustand ziehen kann dieses
video soll der beweis sein es zeigt
routings leibwächter auf dem normandie
gipfel 2009 10 6 agenten begleiten putin
auf die toilette als der präsident
wieder rauskommt trägt einer der
leibwächter beim hinausgehen einen
verdächtigen koffer darin angeblich
putins hinterlassenschaften der
hintergrund ist ein ernster putin soll
angeblich schwer krank sein von krebs
ist die rede und auch von parkinson ende
april tauchten dann diese bilder auf der
camel machthaber wirkte beim treffen mit
seinem verteidigungsminister sergej
schoigu angeschlagen der präsident hielt
sich während des gesprächs an der
tischkante fest weiteres indiz für eine
krankheit putins seine jährliche
fragerunde mit journalisten in wahrheit
eine reine tv propaganda show fiel in
diesem jahr aus oder abgesagt die
gerüchte um den gesundheitszustand von
vladimir putin sie reißen nicht ab und
mit ihnen die hoffnung vieler ukraine
das eine schwere krankheit den kreml
despoten außer gefecht setzt und so den
krieg in der ukraine beenden könnte oder
wie vitali klitschko es jetzt im
interview mit bild.de zib1 heime
ausdrückte
der zustand putins wie steht es wirklich
um den russischen präsidenten seine
leibwächter tun jedenfalls alles dafür
damit dieses streng gehütete geheimnis
nicht ans tageslicht kommt
[Musik]